hello the Internet I'm Gavin derp with a
slow mo guys a while ago Dan you
probably remember this we did a video
with an air bag one air bag yeah got 10
million views and we thought you know
that was fun
let's upscale it a little bit now you
may think Cooper hat pegs right
yeah wrong we've rinsed the scrapyard
425f yeah we come to this huge quarry
because we need a lot more space this
time and what we're going to do is put
loads of powder paint on each air bag
and have a huge explosion where it sort
of goes from one color to the next
let's go get this wired up and a make
the biggest mess we've ever made huge
man all right let's go I think I can
only carry four this will take several
trips one for that one okay so I'm going
to wire these up in this sort of X shape
so one on each edge of that they are
different internally for the wiring well
I think they've all got the same sort of
connect a chance to put a wire on to
each one well the chance of any of these
going off in your hand throwing up
through your head there's no power
source connected at the other end so
they theoretically are that's okay
Michael better luck think that's going
to be a good one looks like some high
end air bag right there didn't they
invent air bags did that yeah they
invented a lot of stuff specially
invented by Dave air bag yeah
[Music]
how exactly you doing it
so what wrapping around you have to do
is wrap around twice and then sort of
squeeze it in into the middle like this
that it's quite tight on the actual air
bag I'm just like now just suddenly
realize that it's a lot the extent of
the mechs we're about to make okay we
can't look like that alone would be too
much mess to clean up and we've got 23
more to fill bit nervous
oh I me too you know I'm nervous that no
one will go out what I've wisely not
connected properly or how we messed this
up I suppose a bit bigger
[Music]
this is going to make a big mess
[Music]
so it looks like we're all primed and
ready to go yeah we are yeah
try to decide where we're going to stand
originally we wanted to be stood you
know sort of in the middle
looking really badass not a little
explosion yeah sort of having it in the
background but then I came up with a
point that essentially we put a load of
airbags next to each other and at any
point one could go off and then hit
another one sort of forwards into the
back of my skull so we'll do it we'll do
it twice yeah and we'll determine if
it's safe to stand in there based on our
first take and if not we'll just yeah
we'll just cower behind the camera okay
go for it you're ready yeah okay so I'm
taking the nail up ready yeah three two
one what'd we miss red and purple looks
like it yeah definitely all the nails
whoa we met mmm lookit wow that looks
awesome does it look so cool it's
actually a really lovely like turquoise
gradient is making the cloud bully
purple dingo off no yellow didn't go off
well no well one of the yellow went off
one yellow one one yellow and off all
the greens all the blues and none of the
other ones went off so this looks
awesome oh yeah okay let's review the
Air Force loam Rachel Adrian actually
one of the yellows went off and only one
you know 1y looks like four yellow bear
I mean that is this slightly thicker but
that still looks awesome two pounds of
paint that's like it's an air bag up
there yeah the yellow air bag took off
oh so that was the excellent we did a
really good job there uh sort of 50%
failure that well less than half of them
went on yeah we've got we got two colors
to go off well the rest of them didn't
even go off at all I will say we made
art that bloody Neil Buchanan would be
proud of he would be blessed so he's not
dead if there's always rumors that you
said it's not dead it's always rumors
all right so we're going to change it up
to hopefully increase our success rate
the one yellow that went off actually
kicked up a howl
a lot of pain yeah so let's just use two
air bags per color it will still be a
hell of a lot yeah and also reduce our
points of failure by 50%
okay then I'm doing a hero pose nice
lunge three two one oh cool it's rainbow
my life
[Music]
that was really successful I was really
kind of nominal but that hiring was
great too like that was perfect so we're
going to make one more change in the
lighting so right now we're back lit
like that shot was so there's not so
much detail on my faces and it's quite
well we look badasses silhouettes yeah
we look like cool silhouette so this
time we're going to change it around
move around change the set so with front
lights in the air bags yeah and sort of
the main puff of color should be a
little bit more bright and now we're
also going to shove an angle in from the
side coming towards the camera which
should look a mental war movie yeah to
be really colorful this is the last one
it's the last one right jump and time it
correctly I'm going to try do a really
cool jump midair cool
wait jump midair jumps emitter I'm gonna
try and do a really cool jump yep mid
explosion sweet so I'm just lingering
you know I'm just going to sort of do
this and then look cool yeah okay
I'm ready I'm ready
you risk this yeah right three two one
whoa that was slightly disconcerting
hahaha flip all I heard was this boom
boom and then I heard like wood for the
floor oh just like what is going on
how's my back so good are you good yeah
I'll be back
[Music]
[Music]
I think I think we timed it right I
don't think my face looks very cool
really concern like oh man when we
practiced it seemed to be all right
Barry so quick but you have not even
like taking off there I like you lower
than I thought I was working though look
at that shot it gives you that suit
looks like ah that's like any background
for our that's a desktop background I'm
unsure of my face care I just like
concentrates in my toes but oh I've
noticed this is the funniest thing about
slow-motion is if you ever do something
and try and look in the lens
you never nail the lens first you always
looking off on it yeah yeah it lasts
forever and slow-mo yeah it's looking
real is he looking that's how you make a
rainbow that looks massive you easy slow
load a rainbow ha ha that is that is one
of my favorite things that we've ever
filmed that it's so cool this angle I
didn't think it would look fat do it
yeah but that's a cool looking thing for
such a tiny period of time yeah like
that was cool for probably 0.01 second
that wicked Hey oh that was terrible
come on you don't ever you have to look
at the old little Albert yeah not really
Yeah right there's my almost yeah yeah
well Dan I think visually that was one
of most delicious things we've ever
filmed that shot of all the colors
coming towards the camera like the
bombing run yeah the mr. men bombing run
yeah but it's decided you're walking
around in the desert that was so cool
amazing
phantom took it in the nose our standard
slo-mo placed it down when there's a bit
of paint on the left there but nothing a
good cloth won't fix so I didn't get
hurt
you didn't get hurt you good and I don't
have to clean up because when a quarry
it's true the rain will just wash this
away we obviously got a deal with these
air bags with a lot of those I can't
want to put a canvas underneath it and
do it again and then just like that we
can keep it moisten it to make it so
it's actually paint rather than powder
things in a way be cool to just walk
into a room with like four different air
bags with different colors and glue the
wards mid estate be like mr. bean
painting a room well hopefully you
thought that video was lovely be sure to
follow us on Twitter
bison much obviously if Dan sees you
wearing a slow mo guys shirt he will buy
you a drink
that is number one slow mo rule and a be
sure to subscribe to the channel we have
a second channel to get that way as well
collective all see you next time